[Music]
here we go again
sony have revealed the ps plus games for
the month of october 2020.
you can download these games when the
store updates on tuesday the 6th of
october
before we look at the horror title let's
check out need for speed payback
i'm certain you've played a need for
speed game in the past whether that's
evading cops or outracing your opponents
on busy streets
but now payback changes things up a
little if you've seen the fast and
furious movies
you know exactly what i mean here you
and your crew are given the task of
stealing a car from a notorious bad guy
and things slowly become more over the
top and extreme
as your past crimes catch up with you
and your friends
need for speed payback takes the open
world racing formula
and by adding these pieces of drama
attempts to grow the series into
something which transcends driving
don't get me wrong though the gameplay
is all about unlocking vehicles
racing at breakneck speeds and
outsmarting the local law enforcement
as you are sucked into the illegal world
of vehicle heists and double crosses
the metacritic score tells us this is a
bang average game
made back in 2017 but if you live your
life a quarter mile at a time
this title should tide you over till
november we can't have a ps plus video
in october without a horror game
and here it is vampire vampire is a
role-playing game
set in industrial london we play as
doctor jonathan reed who is turning into
a vampire
and must learn to control his bloodlust
or embrace it
set in third person in a semi-open world
the doc tries to understand his
condition
and the links to spanish flow unlocking
new abilities as his vampirism takes
over him it's possible to finish the
game without sucking the blood
of any civilians are you up for that
challenge
or are you going in teeth first to
everyone you meet with four endings to
unlock there is replay value here and as
it's halloween it's something to do
while social distancing at home
you could make it your new thanksgiving
thank you
first released in 2018 vampire received
mainly 7 out of 10 review scores
so it's not too shabby but the question
is will you try it
so that's your lot this month like
always sound off in the comments below
but pretty please
don't downvote the video due to the
games down vote it because i'm terrible
at making videos
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time
[Music]